اذا عدا الانتعاش في ايام الصيف الحاره
لاستخدام الماء البارد عند الاستحداء
الاستحمام بذلك الماء البارد فوائد صحيه
عديده بحسب شراء جراحه العظام الامريكيه
شان هام فان اهميه استخدام الماء البارد
تكمن في زياده تدفق الدم والذي يحدث نتيجه
الاجهاد الذي يبذله الجسم من اجل الحفاظ
على درجه حرارته الاساسيه عند تعرضه للماء
البارد بشكل مفاجئ يساعد ذلك بالتاكيد
راويه على زياده تدفق الدم المؤكسد الغني
بالاكسجين والمغذيات الى اجزاء الجسم
المصابه والذي يؤدي الى راحه هذه الاجزاء
وبالتالي التقليل من الشعور بالالم
وبالاعراض المرضيه الاخرى اظهرت نتائج
الدراسه ايضا مشاهدينا او بعض الدراسات
السريريه وجود تاثير ايجابي للحمام البارد
في التخفيف من اعراض اكتئاب ايضا
وتحسين المزاج عليكم بالماء البارد
من السرير للدوش اول شيء لازم اروح على
الحرب بعدين اروح الباء اختمها بالماء
البارد حتى اكون
لانها هي التغير الجو بس عشان لا نستمر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات